so I'm gonna lay out quickly a
five-point plan for how we get from here
to the opening of school in September
again we're gonna ask a lot of parents
of teachers principals all educators to
help us through this path together and
work together to help our kids and it's
gonna get tough and not because the
disease alone but because of the weather
as it gets warmer and warmer our kids
are gonna get more and more restless we
know that so we have to help you through
and we have to give you the best
possible tools the most compelling
options to keep our kids focused on the
distance learning and keep them safe and
indoors for a lot of the day until we
really see things change with this
disease so the first point is to make
sure that the devices the iPads and all
the other devices that were have given
out will give out to kids that every
student who need one needs one gets one
and we will ensure that that happens by
the end of April said of the day we had
to shut down our schools that we knew a
lot of kids just didn't have these
devices and it would be a lag time but
we've gotten great great cooperation
from the companies involved and again
the team at DoD has stepped up we now
need to get devices distributed on a
very fast pace we already can say that
sixty six thousand devices have been
distributed we have to get 240 thousand
more in the hands of our kids over the
next couple of weeks by the end April
and we will do that and then I've said
to the Chancellor whatever it takes the
entire city government will assist to
make sure this happens so that's point
one devices for every child but end
April point to parent helpline we're
going to take the help lines and
hotlines we already have for parents and
that they can reach through three one
one we're going to expand them we're
going to add more we're gonna leave that
press conference there that's the mayor
New York City bill de blasio updating
the public that schools in New York City
are going to now be closed until
September they were expected to reopen
on the 20th of April but parents will
have to clearly be making big
adjustments there as they remain closed
until September nearly six thousand
people have lost their lives in New York
City